thank you
[Music]
anybody see uh in the news recently
there was this
toddler
who was bitten by a snake oh yeah
that [ __ ] looks crazy the Cobra one uh
this would be the photo of both the
toddler and the snake for all of your
viewing that's the dude that got bit in
the face by the door oh no is that to
scale imagine that's to scale yeah snake
two I saw a Cambodian kid or something
getting bit by a snake a cobra and then
his homie was sucking out the blood oh I
did see that one as well it's like a
city slicker but this one this one's a
cute one because it's a toddler right so
the blood sucked the poisonous basically
uh a two-year-old in Bingle turkey
was bitten by the snake and once a snake
bit her on the face she was like ah
picked up a stamp bit it back holy he
killed it wow but isn't that what they
say like you're supposed to do if you
have bitten by a snake you're supposed
to catch it bite back not by back but so
you know that like what kind of snake
bit you or if you tried catching and
bite you four more times
it's like
you die faster from more snake bites
from the same snake probably uh
and yeah if your circulation goes up
that's like oh because you're like Venom
yeah but at a certain point it becomes
anti-venom dude
on the fifth bite yeah like seven and up
come on man the snake won't bite you for
the last time it's all yeah I know what
you're trying to do yeah
so uh yeah she uh she was bitten in
Turkey uh that's not the same kid was it
no that's that's the kid oh that was a
kid and then she decided to bite the the
snake back and she was playing with this
uh snake in her uh family home Garden so
she's just playing with the [ __ ]
random yeah she was just out in the
garden you know there's a snake pops up
in the garden in turkey that's just what
happens uh what's in a venomous snake
snake or not uh I don't think it was
venomous
Peter I better get a garden Shake yeah
garden snake and it just bit her on the
lip uh it's crazy in her in her I guess
automatic response slash maybe not so
much Panic
yeah she took it picked it up started
biting the [ __ ] out of it and then uh
neighbors were horrified when they found
the girl with the 20-inch snake that was
just bitten to death and clamped between
her teeth it was like in her mouth hell
yeah dude [ __ ] G yeah better not bite
me Marcus toddlers don't play around
that's why their Dental Programs so good
there because everyone's biting [ __ ]
snakes and [ __ ] he's reputation no they
grow up biting snakes when they grow up
do you think that would be like a
natural human reaction
dude I think kids maybe maybe like a
two-year-old didn't she used to bite
[ __ ] when you were a kid for no reason
uh I think yeah but I think if something
were to like create harm on me
you know I wouldn't think like oh
revenge like dude if I was two I would
have been crying like a little bit
I'd be crying the whole time I think
biting is a is an attack from kids
because my nephew bit the [ __ ] out of my
cheek dude like my my my
um he was getting frustrated and [ __ ]
because he didn't have his nap and [ __ ]
so like I was like okay I'll [ __ ]
hold him for a second and then when he
was coming to me
he got my face and that food started
biting for dear life and I was like ah
[ __ ] son of a [ __ ] and that it felt
like my mouth was like Mochi and that
that fool's like stretching it out and I
was like trying to [ __ ] pull him out
and I was like damn dude what the [ __ ]
especially kid teeth you're gonna lift
their rear legs oh dude and I remember
when my niece would fight they would
fight with their uh Brothers then she
would uh I think she bit him in the butt
it's pretty so like so like they're like
yeah she turned around and she was like
and [ __ ] bitters [ __ ] butt cheek
and he was like ow you know I think
that's a I think it's an attack using
your teeth yeah one of my cousins who's
like 20 years older than me when she
used to babysit me uh I I remember
distinctly my memory like biting her arm
because that was funny and then like uh
I then I forgot that I did that
and then like years and years later I
was like dang how'd you get that scar
and she goes yeah when you were a kid
you bit me there and then it came back
and I was like oh you bit that hard I
bit that [ __ ] heart she has a scar
and she's like 50 something I bit my mom
like that I remember being like two or
three and my mom would play this game
with like the bugs coming like the bugs
coming the bugs coming and she like
tickled me and I didn't want it she's
like the bugs doing the bugs coming and
I remember uh
one time I was just so frustrated I was
like
and I [ __ ] bid as hard as I could and
my mom just started crying and then I
remember my dad coming home and then uh
my mom she's like what's going on and uh
I told my my dad the story and he
started laughing and I didn't understand
like why my mom would cry and my dad
would laugh oh that was just so little I
didn't understand emotions you know I
was like what
so am I supposed to or no I don't even
know I'll get it home yeah
yeah you better hand I bet that [ __ ] as
hard as I could because it was [ __ ] I
don't want no bug on why you can't be
tickling people dude no yeah Lorenzo
does it all the time really I think it
bites hard oh yeah yeah you yell at him
but then like he thinks it's funny so
keep finally stop and he goes I can't
stop do you know what would happen if I
closed this message do you know who I am
what are you supposed to do when they
bite like that Conor you literally just
you sit there you wait it out because
you can't pull on it because it'll get
worse you don't tell them stop or
something oh yeah a dog or a kid
you're like hey you don't [ __ ] do
that the dog are good it's like anything
kids do to get a guaranteed reaction is
gonna keep doing they're gonna keep
doing it that's why you have to be
audition them to like a different set of
uh boring when they bite you
why are you crying
were you crying no it doesn't hurt just
thinking of a really sad memory
oh the Hindenburg what a tragedy yeah so
it does say specifically that uh she's
very lucky because it wasn't a more
vicious and venomous type of snake
because imagine not only if it was
venomous and she like bites into it and
[ __ ] like that she gets all that poison
I don't know I don't know if that's how
it works with snakes and stuff but still
I think it's going your bloodstream then
it coagulates your blood yeah
you're ingesting it potentially but that
may be just the snake blood because the
Venom is in the fangs um
you get bit by a cobra in the leg or
something
let me pull it up for you I'm watching
jackass and he was like putting his face
he looks like he's like 11. oh snap and
that was taking it like a champ dude
he's like his leg is bit
[ __ ] his homie comes over and just
sucks like the [ __ ] blood out of it
spits it out homie man yeah yeah
and then like he's just taking it like
in the snake's [ __ ] massive too
it's really big snakes are a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] huh have you seen a lot
of snake videos lately yeah it's like
how come it's been very popular on the
[ __ ] Explorer page snake attacks why
why is it all popping up on our [ __ ] I
know it's gonna pop up more now me and
taika and Geo we were hiking and then uh
I think it must have been a trail where
someone hasn't been in a while so like
the wildlife got more comfortable and
then as we're going we just see the
snake go oh go across and then we turn
the corner like maybe another like half
mile down and attack was like oh and
then look at the big snake but this time
it wasn't a big snake it was just one
big ass lizard [ __ ] the other lizard
but it was like this lizard was like
[ __ ] this big and it was just one on
top of each other but they look extra
long and I'm like oh that's that's not a
snake that's a little different they're
they're doing something they're playing
yeah yeah they're they're the Best Buy
they're doing something
you know Taco is that the closest you've
ever had to having to explain sex to him
I think so good thing you didn't say
this is the moment yeah it's time to
swear so the birds and the bees I was
like that's not a snake that's just two
like lizards like wrestling so when two
male lizards each other
they love each other very much look I'm
wrestling like the lizard no no no no no
no no no
taking his bag
I didn't there's apparently a lot of
kids recently have been bit by venomous
snakes so I'm literally seeing a bunch
of random [ __ ] but in front of this
article pulls up that talks about a man
who attended a funeral recently of his
brother who was killed by a snake before
being bitten himself and then also
killed by one no way and also right next
to it there's 18 plus wedding dresses
that made guests uncomfortable
article do you want to be in uh let's
look at that one I wanna what kind of
wedding dresses I don't want to be
uncomfortable though no it's like a skin
paint
yeah it's tight so it's like the whole
[ __ ] wedding party's butt naked and
[ __ ] like that hey I mean if if those
are your type of homies and but then
your family's all showing up aunties and
uncles no this 22 year old man those who
died by snake bite days after he travels
to attend the funeral's brother who had
been killed by a snake that's pretty
[ __ ] curse bro someone did a curse
there's been a rise in snake attacks
here I'm telling you it's been crazy
it's like Nationwide I uh I had a cobra
thrown in a room
um that I was sitting in once it's kind
of crazy what I went to uh when I went
to Vietnam we hung out in the jungle and
uh what they do is they throw a cobra in
the middle of the room and then for fun
yeah for fun and the Snake Charmer is
like you know pissing a snake off and
I'm like dude and the snake sometimes
goes to you right I'm like no no no no
no no no no it's just a surprise like
you're just [ __ ] in line at the
barber shop
yeah but I didn't know they're gonna
throw this snake in the middle of the
room it was a small room and uh they
throw it I'm like dude what the fudge
and he's like catching and stuff like
that and then he hangs up killing it he
hangs it and he slits his chest and then
there's blood dripping into a joke
it's graphic in Vietnam dude
um and they it's like seven you know
seven courses of beef yeah
and so they slit this freaking Cobra and
blood's dripping everywhere my mom yeah
exactly what it is holy [ __ ] oh dude it
gets even crazier so
um they drain the blood all the blood
and then they they you know do whatever
with the meat and whatnot tastes like
fish by the way
um and then they pull the heart out of
the snake and the heart's still beating
whoa yeah and the guest of the honor
gets this part of the snake oh so
everyone's like oh I wish that's me I
need a shot and so they have moonshine
there yeah dude the most drunk I've ever
been on my life this is [ __ ] games
have a half moonshine and half snake
blood and then they put the fish sauce
of course
they put it inside the shot glass and
the heart's still beating so it mixes
because the viscosity
oh what is this I guess the owner gets
in I was guessed the honor at that time
and I freaking took a shot of him as I
took a shot of course it burned and I
felt the heart beating like dude
you know and then it fades away and then
and then right after that you started
[ __ ] growing scales and [ __ ] like
that yeah you ever notice I have a split
tongue oh [ __ ] is so cool
you're right [ __ ] you start fighting
like this is
a snake style dude
my name is Ron skulls
not down with [ __ ] like that
dude that's pretty crazy dude yeah
that's crazy it was one of the cooler
restaurant experiences I've had I
[ __ ] would imagine that's insane
weird stuff man I've had porcupines I've
eaten the Paul of a bear that's the
restaurant at the top floor of the
protector all in Vietnam yeah all the
weird stuff was in Vietnam I ate a dog
once that was horrible was it good
though yeah
that's just Dog's delicious it's really
that's what he said it's like super dry
pork what overly dry pork it was like
one I feel like horrible because like I
love dogs and then tooths isn't even
good where did you like what was the
setting of when where they offered that
yeah oh the restaurant The Dog
restaurant it's also called Petco it's
called Petco
[Music]
um they they chop it it's not seven
courses but they'll chop it up into
different courses like deli meats eat it
with rice and crap
um but it's horrible because there's
like a little mini like Killing Arena
like in the restaurant oh my God you
know illegal's not that cool it's it's
graphic cheese so they say don't leave
your dog out in Vietnam because they'll
steal it and they'll eat it right
there's a there's a region in that
actually a real piece of advice it's not
like a [ __ ] yeah not not like a yeah
sexually real advice make regions
because like do when you cook all the
dogs they all look the same it's effed
up they all look there's no hair
anything they all look the same like
it's I'm like fudge I'm like okay it's
graphic but there's like a little like
bomb down eat it still like I mean I'm
almost down to try anything once you
know I eat it you know you know got it I
was like I don't want to do this Dad
it's like my dad was like in Vietnamese
Like Son you want to hang out with the
men you need to do what men do oh [ __ ]
I'm not the [ __ ] yeah exactly he gave
me that card he's like we're eating dog
you need to eat dog there's no Happy
Meals here and I'm like holy sad please
but the dog does come with a toy
it's their toys it's the last toy the
dog had I know
but you're not even supposed to see the
dog there's like a little mini arena for
some reason but I don't supposed to see
it you're not supposed to but it's like
there for you to look if you want to but
nobody looks if you're mad
so like I peek over because I'm freaking
curious and they have this little it's
only like like a Pomeranian and [ __ ]
your feet and like little medium-sized
dogs unfortunately like the size of my
dog
um like a little 38 pound dog
and uh they throw them in this little
like you know four feet by four feet
little Arena that's where they [ __ ] up
they should have gave you a German
Shepherd you got bigger meat right
um but they they freaking have a what is
a butcher's knife and they freaking
literally they kill the dog like Bear
right on side
well well first they bop it in the head
to get it all delirious and then as it's
Delirious then they start freaking
skinning it while it's alive oh my God
it is so graphic dude I'm just like
bored and all the like is there a
meaning behind it like look it's fresh
we ain't giving you yeah because fake
dog it's not processed like America what
do they because honestly I would assume
the reasoning is probably because it's
more complicated to even like store uh
dog meat no no but like doing it in
front of the customers because like so I
I asked uh I I found out why like the
head is always on the animal when like
Chinese markets and stuff so you know
what's what right so then like oh
because back in the day when they
chopped it all up it's because they're
trying to hide all the old meat so
they're trying to hide and mix it and
then so like you don't know what the
[ __ ] that is so it's like when you're
going to the you know the farmer's
market or whatever they're like I don't
even know if that's fresh but then if
it's the whole animal with the head and
[ __ ] and you can kind of like inspect it
and being like Oh that was freshly
killed today I wonder if it if there's
like a if it works in Reverse where
you're eating dog and you're like you
don't think it's real so you go what is
this chicken
you're all mad
serve me here huh
establishment is this
foreign
[Music]